how are you guys doing we're going to go
ahead and share
what was a very very sad moment when i
heard
that our brother who's been on the
program several times here on the dean
show
when i got the news that we almost lost
them yes we almost lost muhammad hijab
a friend of mine was telling me that he
came close to death
so i started right away in my computer
bank i started going back into the
memory department and i started thinking
about just not so long ago
he was here we were hanging out
he was visiting and we got a chance to
spend some time together to bond
together did some training together
and he even got to uh taste uh one of my
favorite uh protein shakes
and alhamdulillah i visited him there in
the uk
very nice brother he's like a big teddy
bear man and then think that
he was
that close to death yes
so we wanted to derive some some
benefits from this because this is
something that we forget about
many of us we often set the date for our
birth dates
but we forget about the dd departure
date and he was so close to it so i gave
him a call i said muhammad what's going
on what happened i related his story and
this happened a couple months ago but it
seems like
he's in better spirits now let's go
ahead hear
directly from him
what happened what brought him to that
state and how can we take some benefit
from this because we take a lot of
things for granted so i'm giving my
thoughts
on this after we hear the firsthand
account from our brother muhammad hijab
no because then i got blood clot
no yeah
yeah yeah i got i i myself got pulmonary
embolism that's awesome yeah yeah i got
a pulmonary embolism from it what
happened
how long ago was this this was some
months ago some months ago yeah is it
okay now now i'm all right you know
no no no no no
no no i i took the vaccine
i got uh primary embolism yeah because
about 10 days after i took the vaccine
i'm here filming people would you mind
saying this
and then some 10 days 11 days later
i was coughing up blood
so i was thinking what's this
in fact i came to speaker's corner on
that day i was thinking i'm losing my
fitness i'm losing because what happens
when you have pulmonary embolism is that
you your breathing becomes very short
short breathing something yeah yeah so
what happened after that
is one of my friends here in the park
they took me to the hospital i said i
want to stay here man jennifer said so
they took me to st mary's yeah which is
nearby
and we've done a blood test well you
know they do something called a d-dimer
which is like the
so i've done the d-dimer okay
blood test and they said that you've you
can't go you can't leave the hospital i
said what's going on he said you've got
a blood clot i said come on i want to go
home i'll waste my time
so what happened after that
was um they said okay you've they looked
at it
and i had what you call lung infarction
as well right what happens is when you
get a pulmonary embolism
pulmonary
yeah there are two there are three
different arteries
you know there are so you call it
segmental arteries the the sub-segmental
arteries and then you've got the primary
artery yeah the segmental archery is
like the medium one the the the
subsequent was the smallest one the
pulmonary artery is like the thickest
one
if the blood clot goes through the
pulmonary artery it kills you
this is sudden death
it's southern death yeah so what
happened was my one was in the segmental
artery so it's not so you've got you've
got you've got your palm reality you've
got
three then you have the sub segmental
artery
are my blood clots because there was
there was many of them yeah it came
through the
the segment archery yeah
so what it is is that they looked at
they done us a mri and you know a ct
scan i should say yeah
and they sort of what happens when you
have pulmonary embolism is it a lung
infarction is basically when you have
death of the lung
so my left lung basically died part of
it
and it doesn't come back to life
it's probably damage it's permanent
damage it's permanent damage wow now the
thing is
when i was speaking to something i went
to more than one hospital because i had
more than one episode yeah
i spoke to a few people
and
from the doctors they're telling me that
yeah do you know what people died from
this like your age
and when with me i insisted they i mean
the guys knew me in the hospital
whatever they've done the yellow card
yeah which is to say that they reported
it that i had what you call an
unprovoked
situation
but a lot of times it's not the case
look i'm 29 i'm 29 years old 29 yeah i
for me personally i took the vaccine i
was not i you know i was not erring in
the side of caution from that
perspective but i regretted it
now i'm getting messages on my phone
saying take the second dose
if you don't take the second dose
whatever happened that you got all these
consequences and genuinely
i've taken the vaccine as per the
recommendation of the government
than what every law abiding citizen is
meant to do
ten days later i was on the brink of
dying in a hospital coughing out blood
and couldn't breathe and some therefore
in some therefore
i will say this i will say i'm not
saying to anybody i'm not saying don't
take vaccines i'm not saying it's up to
you what you want to do with your life
i'm not going to tell you what to do
honestly this is a genuinely as a
personal decision yes but what i am
going to say is from my experience as a
29 year old yeah when i took
that vaccine 10 days later i was they
were telling me we need to see for the
first five days whether you're gonna
survive or not that's what they told me
already in place but you have to make
sure by the way you have the will you
know you will actually be ready you know
the muslim community especially no
you've got to be ready to die you know
if you're if you're not ready to die
you're not living wow that's very deep
but it's very very nice i'm elated to
see him in good spirits alhamdulillah
taking things
very well
and just imagine being in that situation
you're coughing up blood hard time to
breathe
and now
you're right in your will you're getting
ready to go
and
why is it that this is something that's
so stressed upon in our deen to reflect
over this and these are lessons a couple
of them that we can take from this like
i started off in the beginning many
people set the date for the bd the birth
date but what about the departure that
you just don't know
when or where it can come young man has
his whole life in front of him and then
he gets that
that warning that wake up call it can be
taken all of it can be taken away the
children can be left behind the wise can
be left behind the husband if you're a
woman can be left behind children can be
left behind everything as we know in
this world we don't actually own it's
all gonna be left behind
now let me share a few statements
authentic statements from the last and
final messenger sent to mankind prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
who
helps to bring this reality home this is
an authentic hadith
he said paradise is closer to one of you
than the strap of his sandal and so is
the hellfire
look at this if someone says you are
that close
to receiving
life in prison
you are that close to receiving
a billion dollars
which one would you go ahead
and chase and run after or try to
keep away from you
a life of torture
that cannot even be compared to the
hellfire
it's that close
as he's explaining just get that visual
basically the shoestring of your shoe
that's how close it is to you
to all of us
and
our brother muhammad hijab came close to
that reality there's another hadith an
authentic hadith i want to share with
you
where the prophet saws said live as long
as you want to live
because eventually you will die so go
ahead you think you're going to live 100
years 200 years of science
put something together that you they can
expand your life for a year or two even
though the quality of life just
continues to decline as you get older go
ahead
and he says because eventually you're
going to die then he goes on to talk
about work as you wish for you will be
repaid accordingly love whomever you
wish for you will separate you will be
departed eventually
know that the nobility of the believer
is prayer
at night and his honor is his
independence from the people so go ahead
and love who you're going to love work
for what you're going to work for
because
the one you love you're going to have to
be separated from
that work you'll get paid accordingly
and at the end of the day
you will
depart from this life again another
reality hit home that's the beautiful
thing about our dean
it holds things in a perfect balance now
the last hadith i want to share with you
revolving around this topic of death
that our brother came so close to
is also in muslim
and the prophet saw some said when a man
dies when a person dies when a human
being dies his good deeds come to an end
except three which three the ongoing
charity beneficial knowledge and a
righteous son who will pray for him a
righteous child who will pray for him
listen to this
all of the things that we accumulate
again this is a reminder as i said
earlier is going to stay behind except
those three things ongoing charity so it
encourages us to go ahead and give
beneficial knowledge it goes and
encourages us to share that's how we're
sharing this information inshallah
hoping that it gets accepted and then
raising righteous children
and a child can be a doctor an engineer
but that's not the ultimate goal if they
lose their deen they lose themselves in
this dunya
so alhamdulillah that our brother seems
like he's in much better spirits and
he's handling this quite well
but for all of us out there we can take
from this example
what's the example that def you can
think just like he was he never thought
that something like this was going to
happen but it happened all of a sudden
it happened quickly and then he was
preparing that he can end up at any
moment being separated from his family
from his loved one so let's go ahead and
take heed the intelligent person is the
one who thinks about death often thinks
about the destroyer of pleasures and
that is death and it helps us to live a
balanced
life that we go ahead and take our share
from this dunya because the dua that we
make from the verbatim word of god
almighty the quran
is o allah the creator heavens and earth
grant us the best in this life and the
best in the hereafter so we want the
best of this life the good of this life
the pure of this life
but
our eye is set on the ultimate prize and
that is jenna paradise because that's
the life forever ever yes forever ever
yes this life will end there is a dd in
the next life there's no departure date
once you arrive
you're on that pure monotheism you're
doing good deeds you're living a good
wholesome life a righteous life the way
your creator created you to live then
you get his mercy mercy you get his
grace but if you're not establishing the
dean you're not establishing prayer you
ended up go ahead and you're drifting
off and you're just concerned about
partying playing you're just about
impressing dressing to impress the boys
you're just worried about what he or
she's going to say
you're not concerned more
appropriately about what your creator
is going to say
and what your creator is going to do at
the end
because all those actions are not in
line with how allah wants us to live so
we want to stay away from the backbiting
the gossiping we want to stay away from
all those things that can lead to
destruction because a person will do one
evil deed thinking like hey it's not a
big deal but in the sight of the crater
it is huge
and you're just brushing it off like
it's a fly
but
those
these continue to pile up and pile up
until you have a whole collection of
those and it's like a
huge
huge fire
from those small little twigs
so this is first for myself we all are
sinners we all make mistakes
i'm the first
one to admit this
but the best of sinners are those as the
prophet some said all of the sons of
adam are sinners but the best of those
are those who are constantly in towbad
so may allah protect us from hypocrisy
may allah protect us from having an evil
end may allah protect us
from the love of this dunya and may he
give us the best of it and then grant us
the eternal bliss in jannah
in jannah we'll see you next time here
on the dean show until then peace be
with you subscribe if you haven't
already hit that notification bell peace
be with you islamic